こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん英会話英会話教室行ったことはありますでしょうか
あの
イバカがやることは絶対に真似しないで下さいこともやっちゃダメなことだと思って
やっております今回やってみたいのはこちら英会話教室で英語禁酒しているとどうなる
か
あのすいません純粋な疑問ですや
値段は家事をめっちゃくちゃ悪いことなんですよ英語を教える食うか英語せる先生
そして英語を喋れないしゃべらない人のこれここでなんてもう6寸が生じてるその矛盾
が生ずる空間で何が起きるかっていうの方がちょっとやってみようと思います絶対マネ
しないでくださいねマジでよくないですからねあの本当の a 階級制に行こうと思っ
たんですけどもさせにそれは
炎上するなと思いまして時々英会話教室を今回作らせていただきました生徒は全員
エキストラ先生は本物なんですけどもあのもう何してもいいという許可はいただいて
おります仮想英会話教室をつくりましたなんて普通に授業もはじまるシーンも生徒も
先生も本物同然のようにやっていただくのねその中で僕が英語禁止で英会話教室に入る
とどういう空気になる
のかもう空気の勉強です今回は僕の対応力がすごい大事になると思うんでいかに日本語
で切り返せるか頑張りたいと思います
英語よ
[音楽]
conoha
大丈夫方だという金額
wh
yuichi レイクルイーズいい
ok
[音楽]
ん
ルーブ単位だけ face to do
nao
ん
pea いっ
いっ
ユニスキルがいい
ipf が実戦4 tseng the bridge ディスプレーしたい
a お知恵
始め ok うっと
始めせっかく v 堂元溥 a
ok さあ型入試てきます
ミーティング術と言わしめボシュッ芸 new
ギザなぁ秋 n
lef ren
似合うキープ
伊豆原
ん
んか
べぃ
剣道ガールズけど
no 不平件健勇銃剣道
19件
重要件
ok にぐです
倹約にかっ
筋肉言ってゆくもうターン言わればいいの
金融が緩さゴッ
[音楽]
の時にさん
矢部町土ケウできます
下 nud からでん
ん
うん
愛犬中09 d
賢者いうか
バーン ok だけ
ん
i 型女子御膳開け
エロ財政うん
三小学校アークあ
おっの渦
隣国パットっと
アップルエアー
ん
い続け
プルっ
voodoo
自転車
ヴァイス号
ヴァイス後を追った
ず電車
by スーツ
車カー
うん
犬 the name 水上
うーん
犬
じゃあ hey
ですねあげてを向いて助成金言え
[音楽]
卵ん
ええええええ
ぐうっ
牛耳ない a 4 a
う h ない a
ビッグエー
シェイク
me
teal
car
ana あああっ
あるんです後 sorry 鉄道系さくらの英語教師2
で英語禁酒してました wired を
アプリを20スポッチャ言ったぞ
にゃん
[音楽]
にゃんカーボン皆さん絶対真似しないようにしてください